hey guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a man
that you all voted for in my community
post you all voted for kevin samuels
for me to react to i'm not gonna lie the
more videos i watch of him
he says the same thing over and over
again
so we'll see if this is any different
he kind of tells me that i might as well
just have no value
after the age of 35. is it over for me
in life
like should i just like roll over and be
done
but yeah this is um kevin samuels slap
and salute highlights
also don't forget to subscribe i'm
trying to grind guys i really want to
get 15
000 before sunday that's really my goal
don't forget
hit that subscribe button ding
i'm like pretend i'm too lazy to edit it
in okay i'm gonna start
what's he doing is he just okay
can you young ladies think that this is
a game
23 is not young when you have a child
you're over here breathing like a
petulant teenager
i just feel like you're not really
hearing me
you're not listening to how
okay see
so what he does when he kicks woman off
his show
damn
why did i do that because
that would have gone on for five hours
just like this and i want to tell you
something notice the difference between
the emotional maturity of the 22 year
old
and the 42 year old
notice the emotion notice how they were
talking
it's not fair it's not this it's not
that our black women
have been sold a disney fantasy
of relationship and marriage
it's probably me because it's definitely
i'm jesse no it's not it's not
no no no ma'am it's not it's not busy
busy then what is it
were you raised with your mother and
father were your mother father mary yes
they were
okay um have you ever saw therapy
have you excuse me
no i'm asking she got defensive have you
all right let me let you get your big
ass up off my show
because okay i don't do this stupid fat
chick [ __ ]
see this is why i don't deal with what i
tell you guys these these
big fat attorneys
with all this attitude talking about she
chose to be single
and i'm supposed to sit around and just
be nice to this delusion
as this land well a question and she
gets an attitude
nobody would choose to be single if they
had like the right partner when people
say they choose to be single
they just mean like i didn't like the
options that i have
[Music]
i'm sorry man but that's just the way it
is for all women
a man coming to take care of another
man's
offspring is settling that's a beta male
move i've done it
you you you bet i would be really
curious to ask kevin samuels like
why like what did those women
have to offer that made you want to
marry them like why why did you do it
like he always talks about how like
single mothers can't get a guy like a
quality guy but
if he thinks he's a quality guy he
married a single mother
baby mama's got it really twisted i
understand you can love your child your
child special but all it is to another
man is a damn
bill
and what's the difference all right
that's it that's it
you you're not gonna listen no
it's not gonna listen
peace out
[Music]
oh he does this for every girl but he
kicks off his show doesn't he
[Music]
damn
we're gonna have to continue to do these
baby mama shows because here's the thing
no matter how i try to talk to you no
matter how i try to say it
it's the same thing understand this and
understand this well
if you go out and make a baby outside
the bonds of marriage
you are cutting off your opportunity for
high
value men the reason i called in
was because i just wanted to say
hi value man
this is interesting because
my sister got remarried but i don't know
if he would be high value or not but he
made
he makes six figures and like
i don't know he's a good husband to her
i just okay
what bothers me that bothers me but like
a lot of these women come at him with
attitude
so i think that's why they get like his
like sass or whatever
but i'd be interested to hear him like
talk more about like
strategies for women that are like in
those situations i know he'd obviously
say to lose weight but like
you know single mothers get remarried
like
it happens my sister had
two kids from a previous marriage and
she got remarried
and like you know what i mean like it
happens
so i'd just be curious to see like why
it happens for those women and like
what advice he would give to women in
that situation
yes i agree with you black women need to
do a better job
with taking care of their health i agree
with
but all i'm saying is that's not the
only thing
a black woman brings to them get off my
channel
i didn't even think she was that rude
that's that's not all a black woman
brings to the table
now she brings mayonnaise she bring
kool-aid she brings sugar
she bring a goddamn purse full of
peppermints
you got snacks and treats hidden all up
in that bonnet
no hell to the no call my show think you
can
you're an image consultant well i'm an
educated black
only in our community
can a professional man who does this for
a living
have a woman think just because she went
to school
that what her opinion matters more
i actually don't believe that going to
school makes you smarter
at all like i went to college i have a
degree in economics
and business administration i almost had
a minor in political science too but
like
i had to do one like two more classes my
last semester and i was like nah
but like you know what i'm saying like
i'm pretty educated and i
seriously don't like educated but i
think i've learned more
i swear to god from doing youtube this
past like six months
than i have
in college roughly roughly i'd say
another six months i'll know more about
like running a business than i learned
in college did you want to be though
the father of your children excuse me
ma'am
excuse me ma'am excuse me ma'am
the men you chose to bring life onto
this planet the men you chose to breathe
life onto this planet are not high-value
men
you don't work with any high-value men
you don't know any high-value men
so basically what you're gonna train so
what you're going to do is tell women a
bunch of bs
fantasy ladies women like this are your
enemy
never listen to a woman who had two
children and was not even married tell
you about what it takes to get a high
value
competitive or successful man we have
too much of this
foolishness going on in the black
community she went to san hotep
college i'm gonna try to tell you that i
could have gotten to princeton because i
wanted to
i went to red black and green university
i could get into yale
going to a d3 school i relate because
everyone's like i could have went d1
i could have went d1 like that's all
they ever say
or the guys in the football team it was
a d3
losing football team and these guys have
talked about how they're going to the
league
what do you mean what league i know damn
sure it's not the nfl
just my two cents
like a flag football league on saturdays
with your friends maybe
[Music]
name don't even make sense nasa rasa
rest in pasta pasta the next one
the next one this one is gonna hurt
i need you ladies to go ahead and get
get your glass get your riesling
or your pinot noir or your zinfandel or
whatever i need to go ahead and take a
a take a good good three get a good
mouthful
don't just step take a big gulp nah he
wants you to lose weight
don't sip don't step ladies it's a trap
okay
if you don't drink wine fine get your
scoop get your haagen-dazs
and put the teaspoon down and go ahead
and get you the whole tablespoon don't
even get the tablespoon
go get that big wooden spoon and get you
a big wooden spoon
of ice cream and go ahead and chug that
down your pie hole
uh-uh he says to lose weight okay
this one's gonna hurt
this one's gonna hurt
let me go ahead and do that for myself
[Music]
all right ladies
leading with your education or your
degree is a non-starter with men because
it's masculine
these were funny not as funny as i
thought they were going to be like
they're kind of funny but i've seen
funny or stuff
i don't really have any comments like
he was just roasting women the whole
time let me know what you guys think
in the comments like comment
comment below if you want me to do more
kevin samuels reactions or if you have
someone else you would prefer
and subscribe get me to that 15 000 by
sunday